Oh, just another cold open for the show here, huh? Maybe it'll be interesting this time. I don't know. Maybe you guys can say something. Well, if you keep your mouth shut, it will be. Go ahead, Will. It's not supposed to be interesting. It's just an amuse-bouche.
噢，这只是节目的又一个冷开场，对吧？也许这次会很有趣。我不知道。也许你们能说点什么。好吧，如果你闭上嘴，就会很有趣。说吧，威尔。这本来就不是为了有趣。它只是个开胃小菜。
Oh, I speak French. My name's Will. Amuse-bouche. I'm from Canada, so I knew two languages, you stupid ass. Oh, well. Can't wait for your next visit to Canada. Hope you like bricks in the face. Welcome to SmartLess.
噢，我懂法语。我叫威尔。开胃小菜。我来自加拿大，所以我懂两种语言，你个蠢货。好吧。真期待你下次访问加拿大。希望你喜欢脸上挨砖头。欢迎来到 SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. Would people be interested or repulsed at all if they looked at your search history, either one of you? Do you guys get creepy on the internet? Do you get sort of like, well, I can kind of anonymously check out this subculture.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。如果别人看了你们俩的搜索历史，不管是哪一个，大家会感兴趣还是觉得恶心？你们在网上会变得有点猥琐吗？你们会不会有那种“嗯，我可以匿名去看看这个亚文化”的想法？
Do you guys do any of that? We should read our search history on an episode. Huh. That would be nice. Actually, the other person should read it so that you can't self-edit. That's true. Mine is pretty benign.
你们会做这种事吗？我们应该在一期节目里读一下我们的搜索历史。哈。那倒挺有意思的。其实，应该让另一个人来读，这样你就没法自我编辑了。没错。我的搜索记录挺无害的。
And mine is a lot of Wikipedia holes that I go on that you'd be astonished at. You'd be like, wow, is this guy bored? Mine is about world events and how I can help and reach out to hundreds of millions of people and offer my advice and my experience in life. Jason, I'm guessing, by the way, you looked at it. I'm guessing yours would be soy sauce near me.
我的嘛，有很多维基百科的无底洞，你看了一定会大吃一惊。你会觉得，哇，这家伙是有多无聊？我的都是关于世界大事的，以及我如何能够提供帮助、接触到数亿人，并提供我的人生建议和经验。杰森，我猜——顺便说一句，从你刚刚的表情来看——我猜你的会是“我附近的酱油”。
Is that true? No, why do we always talk about my puffy face? It's probably my fault every morning. You guys, let's get to it. Sure. Do you guys get nervous when it's not your guest? I'm a little nervous. Are you serious?
是真的吗？不，为什么我们总是在谈论我浮肿的脸？每天早上这可能都怪我。各位，我们切入正题吧。当然。当来的不是你们自己的嘉宾时，你们会紧张吗？我有点紧张。你是认真的吗？
I get nervous when it's my guest. No, I always get a little nervous. Who is this going to be? Oh, you're going to be so excited. I love her. Nervous is probably the wrong word. No, no, no. This person.
当来的嘉宾是我自己人时，我才紧张。不，我总是有点紧张。这会是谁呢？噢，你们会兴奋得不行的。我太喜欢她了。紧张可能用错词了。不，不，不。这个人。
I'm guessing it's her. This lady is a phenomenal actress. I've been a great admirer. Meryl Streep. Who? Meryl Streep? No, it's just about. Or just as popular and successful.
我猜是她。这位女士是一位非凡的女演员。我一直是个超级崇拜者。梅丽尔·斯特里普。谁？梅丽尔·斯特里普？不，只是关于……或者同样受欢迎和成功。
I've been a great admirer of hers for a long time. She got her start in the business with an acting role in A Time to Kill in 1996. No way. You know I loved her in Hidden Figures because it was about NASA. Coincidentally, we both had roles in the international. Smash it.
我仰慕她很久了。她1996年在《杀戮时刻》中获得了一个演艺角色，从而开启了演艺生涯。不会吧。你知道我很喜欢她在《隐藏人物》里的表现，因为那是关于美国宇航局的。巧合的是，我们在《国际》里都有角色。大获成功。
Win a date with Ted Hamilton. She is an Academy Award winner, has co-starred, guest starred, and most importantly, starred in a Kajillion hit projects. But you absolutely know her and love her for making that shit pie in the help my girlfriend Octavia spent. Octavia. I just worked with Octavia.
《情迷伊甸园》。她是一位奥斯卡奖得主，曾联合主演、客串出演，最重要的是，在无数热门项目中担任主演。但你绝对知道她并喜爱她，因为她在《帮助》里做了那个狗屎派，我女朋友奥克塔维亚花了……奥克塔维亚。我刚刚和奥克塔维亚合作过。
And didn't we have fun? Oh, yes. And what was the movie again? This was Thunder Force with our good friend Melissa McCarthy. And it was a super hero type of thing. It was so fun. So fun. We have not worked together.
我们玩得开心吗？噢，是的。那部电影叫什么来着？这是《雷霆女神》，和我们的好朋友梅丽莎·麦卡西一起。那是一部超级英雄类型的片子。太有趣了。太有趣了。我们还没有一起合作过。
So hello and nice to meet you. So nice to meet you. I'm a fan. I'm a fan. Well, wait till you meet him. I'm a fan of yours. My god, I mean, we're so delighted to have you here. Yeah, this is so great.
所以你好，很高兴认识你。很高兴认识你。我是你的粉丝。我是你的粉丝。好吧，等你见到他就知道了。我是你的粉丝。天哪，我的意思是，你能来我们太高兴了。对，太棒了。
You know, we shared the same publicist Octavia. And I'm always asking her, we know who she is. What's Octavia up to? Would you ever want to hang out with me? And I ran into you at a charity event quite a while ago. And I was just like, I couldn't believe I was meeting you. I've been a fan. You couldn't believe you were at a charity event.
你知道的，我们和同一个公关奥克塔维亚合作。我总是问她——我们都知道她是谁——奥克塔维亚最近在忙什么？你有没有想过和我一起出去玩？很久以前我在一个慈善活动上碰到了你。我当时就觉得，简直不敢相信能见到你。我一直是你的粉丝。你简直不敢相信自己是在一个慈善活动上。
Yeah, exactly. Did you pull in to ask for directions somewhere? Yeah. She looked like she had a GPS that was working. Well, it's so nice to have you here. Thank you. It's good to be here. I want to start right at the very beginning.
对，没错。你是把车开过去问路的吗？对。她看起来像是在用一个好用的GPS。好吧，你能来真是太好了。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。我想从最开始聊起。
You come from a huge family, like me. And wait, how huge is huge? Seven. Good. Wow. I'm so jealous. Seven kids. That's just sounds.
你来自一个大家庭，就像我一样。等等，到底有多大？七个。不错。哇。我太嫉妒了。七个孩子。听起来……
I immediately think about all the family holiday gatherings. And there's just people running around everywhere. Is that am I right? That is quite accurate. And even more people now that people have kids. Right. Yeah, I would love that. You look like it's a stressful experience.
我立刻想到了所有家庭节日聚会。到处都是跑来跑去的人。是这样吗？我没说错吧？完全正确。现在大家都有了孩子，人就更多了。对。是的，我会很喜欢那样的。你看上去觉得这是一次很有压力的经历。
Yeah, let's get into the dirt. Who do you wish was not there? Who would you like to no longer come? Yeah, let's go there. Oh, that's great. Let's go around the horn. If you could go back, let's name family members we would not like to ask.
对，我们来八卦一下吧。你希望谁不在现场？你希望谁以后都别来了？对，我们聊聊这个。噢，这太棒了。我们挨个问一问。如果你能回到过去，我们说出几个不想邀请的家庭成员。
Let's start on your mother's side. I want to talk about something that's so interesting to me, though. You started in casting. Wow, really? And so I want to know lots of things about that. I want to know, does it make you better an actor? And also, as you're doing it, as you were doing casting
从你母亲那边开始吧。不过，我想聊一件让我觉得非常有趣的事。你是从选角导演做起的。哇，真的吗？所以我想知道很多关于这方面的事。我想知道，这会让你成为一个更好的演员吗？还有，当你做这件事的时候，当你以前在做选角时……
and had a voice in choosing maybe if an actor got a part, what's it like knowing that their livelihood depends on choices that you guys discuss behind closed doors? I mean, it's a big decision to cast or not cast somebody in a role. Well, let me clarify. I never really got to participate in saying who got a job. I was like a reader, and I got to learn
并且对某个演员是否能得到角色有话语权时，知道他们的生计取决于你们在闭门会议中讨论做出的选择，这是一种什么感觉？我的意思是，决定是否让某人出演一个角色是一个重大的决定。好吧，我澄清一下。我从来没有真正参与过决定谁能得到工作。我只是个读剧本的配戏演员，我通过选角过程学到了很多东西……
through the casting process. But it was one of those things you can't teach. You can teach auditioning technique, but there's a difference in actually being in the room and watching what actors do. But it was different, though, because I worked in the Southeast. And then when I moved out here, things that we did in the Southeast kind of didn't go,
但这真的是一门无法教授的学问。你可以教试镜技巧，但真正身处房间里并观察演员们的表现是完全不同的体验。不过情况有所不同，因为我在美国东南部工作。后来我搬到这里后，我们在东南部做的那套行不通了。
because we took props and auditions. That's taboo. Oh my god, I actually gave a friend. I was like, you need to go in there. When I worked in the Southeast, all over Virginia, Florida, Alabama, all across the. And people would come in if they were going to be a waitress in a scene.
因为我们在试镜时带了道具。那是禁忌。天哪，我以前居然给过一个朋友建议。我说过：“你得走进去。”当我还在东南部工作时，跑遍了弗吉尼亚州、佛罗里达州、阿拉巴马州，到处都是……人们来试镜时，如果演的是个女服务员。
They would have their little notepads, or they would have a little phone. And so I had a couple of friends who were like, you worked in casting. What should I do in this audition? And Tate Taylor, I'll never get over it. He was, I think, testing for a job. And I said, you've got to stand out.
他们会带着自己的小笔记本，或者拿个小手机。所以我有几个朋友问我：“你做过选角，我这次试镜该怎么做？”泰·泰勒——我永远忘不了。他当时好像在为一个工作试镜。我说：“你得脱颖而出。”
You've got to stand out from everybody else. You should take a phone. And this was before we had cell phones. I had to pull out one of the phones that had the. With a cord on it? Like a corded phone. No, it was a long antenna. So we took it out and literally pulled out the antenna
你必须在所有人中脱颖而出。你应该带个手机。”这是在我们有手机之前。我不得不掏出那种带有……带根线的电话？就像带绳子的座机。不，它有一根很长的天线。所以我们把它拿出来， literalmente 掏出天线……
and started the, you know, did his test, poor thing. And then he got a phone call. He got a phone call right in the middle of the audition. He got a phone call as he was walking to his car. And I learned then never to never give anybody any pointers. You must have seen so many. Being a reader, I've done that before as well. I remember once I helped out a casting director years ago
然后开始，你知道的，进行他的测试，可怜的家伙。然后他接到了一个电话。他在试镜进行到一半时接到了电话。他在走向汽车时接到了电话。从那时起我吸取了教训，再也不给任何人提任何建议了。你一定见过各种各样的人。作为配戏演员，我以前也做过。我还记得几年前我帮过一个选角导演……
on, what was that movie that it was Richard Geer in? Edward, Primal Fear. Primal Fear, I auditioned for that. Well, they had a big, huge casting calls in New York and Chicago and everything. And so you obviously auditioned for that. And I helped in the Cato Cole in New York. But you must have seen some horror story auditions before.
那是理查·基尔演的那部什么电影来着？爱德华……《一级恐惧》。《一级恐惧》，我去试镜过那部戏。嗯，他们在纽约和芝加哥等地举行了盛大的公开选角。所以你显然去试镜了。我在纽约的选角环节帮了忙。但你以前一定见过很多可怕的试镜故事。
Do you have any, because I'm going to take this, I'm going to take a page out of Sean's, one of his books in the back that he hasn't read. And say, what was your worst casting nightmare that you were witness to? Oh man, the worst. We're just saying bear it, like cringe worthy where you just felt like, oh gosh,
你有什么——因为我要借鉴肖恩的一招，翻看他那本没读过的书后面的一页——说吧，你亲眼目睹过的最糟糕的选角噩梦是什么？噢天哪，最糟糕的。我们说的是那种赤裸裸的、让人尴尬到脚趾抠地、让你觉得“天哪……
I wish I was in here right now. Oh gosh. While you're thinking of one, I have one. I played the piano for auditions for musicals and I played the piano for Annie, right? For all the kids coming into audition and I had to play tomorrow over and over again, right? And there's a song called, I know I'm going to like it here.
我真希望现在不在这个房间里”的经历。天哪。在你思考的时候，我有一个。我曾为音乐剧试镜弹钢琴，我为《安妮》弹过钢琴，对吧？为所有来试镜的孩子们弹，我不得不一遍又一遍地弹《明天》，对吧？还有一首歌叫《我知道我会喜欢这里》。
Do you know that song? I know I'm going to like it here. And you hold the beat, right? And this girl comes in and she stands there and she goes, she actually counts the numbers under her breath while she's holding the note. So she goes, I know I'm going to like it here to see her high six, seven, eight.
你知道那首歌吗？《我知道我会喜欢这里》。你要保持节奏，对吧？然后这个女孩进来了，她站在那里说——她甚至在保持音符的同时，在嘴里小声数着拍子。所以她说：“我知道我会喜欢这里（唱：二三四五六七八）。”
Oh my God. She must have been like six years old. Bless her. So fun. Bless her. God, I wish I would have seen you back then, Sean. What, just let me know, what was the hair strategy when you were playing piano in auditions?
噢天哪。她当时大概六岁吧。真可怜。太有趣了。真可怜。天哪，肖恩，我真希望那时候就能见到你。对了，告诉我，你当年在试镜时弹钢琴的发型策略是什么？
Sure. So my hair strategy was just to cut as close to a bowl as I possibly could. You had a bowl, a bowl cut? Absolutely. Oh my God. How much were you giving to the company that Depp, that made Depp gel? How much money of your money did they get?
好的。所以我的发型策略就是剪得尽可能像个锅盖头。你留过锅盖头？绝对的。噢天哪。你为那个生产发胶的公司贡献了多少？他们从你身上拿走了多少钱？
Oh no, L'Oreal spritz, L'Oreal spritz all the way. And what about Moose? What happened to Moose? Where did Moose go? Moose didn't hold, Moose didn't hold. It didn't, did it? Not Moose bit. Wait, so, so, so, so we've gone through the hair thing.
哦不，欧莱雅喷雾，欧莱雅定型喷雾。那摩丝呢？摩丝去哪了？摩丝定型效果不好，摩丝定型不住。是不是？摩丝不行吗？等等，等等，等等，等等，我们已经聊完发型了。
So then, so you're working in casting, what's the moment? Is it one of those great miracle stories? Are you reading and the director is there and says, hang on a second, the reader is the best actor we've had in here today? Is that what happened? Please tell me as that's what happened. It made me want to act because on most of the jobs
那么，接着你在选角部门工作，哪个瞬间是转折点？这是那些伟大的奇迹故事之一吗？你在读词，导演也在场，然后说：“等一下，这个配戏演员是我们今天见到的最好的演员”？是这样吗？请告诉我这就是发生的事情。这让我萌生了当演员的想法，因为在我们参与的大多数工作中……
that we worked on, whenever we were doing the smaller roles, the director would say, you know, I want somebody with a personality or like Octavia. So I would always get offered these parts and I would politely turn down. Wow, sure. Because I was a professional and I couldn't mix it up. And that just makes them want you more.
每当我们做一些小角色时，导演就会说：“你知道的，我想要一个有性格的人，或者像奥克塔维亚这样的人。”所以我总是被提供这些角色，而我会礼貌地拒绝。哇，真的吗？因为我是个专业人士，我不能把这些混为一谈。这只会让他们更想要你。
Well, exactly. That's what Jason, Jason, what do you call that? Yes. Sexy indifference. Sexy indifference. Sexy indifference. So I'll bet you having seen everyone come through the door, it made you feel a little bit more confident
嗯，完全正确。杰森，杰森，你管这叫什么？是的。性感冷漠。性感冷漠。性感冷漠。我敢打赌，看过每个人走进来之后，每当轮到你站在另一边时，都会让你感觉更有自信……
each time you were on the other side, right? Because, you know, the imagination goes to a place where like everybody is better than me in general in life. But then when you see people come through like, oh, well, I can compete with that, you know? I wish more actors could be on the other side and see that you're plenty talented. I have to tell you that I would recommend it.
对吧？因为，你知道的，人的想象力总是会倾向于认为“总体来说，生活中的每个人都比我优秀”。但当你看到人们走进来时就会想：“噢，好吧，我完全能跟这些人竞争，你知道吗？”我希望更多的演员能站在另一边，看看其实你们非常有才华。我得告诉你，我强烈推荐这么做。
But now with everything being the way that it is, people are putting themselves on tape and won't ever get that experience. But it totally demystified what happened in the room for me. So I, but I would say to anybody that can help cast a student film just to see what different actors do. Cause here's the interesting thing.
但现在随着一切都变了，人们都是自己录视频交磁带，再也体验不到那种经历了。但这彻底解开了房间里发生的事情在我心中的神秘感。所以我会对任何能帮学生电影选角的人说，去看看不同的演员是怎么表现的。因为这里有趣的地方在于：
When it's written out in the breakdown in the script and all of that, people come in and a lot of people make the exact same choice because it's worded that such and such does this. We're looking for a 30 to 40 year old who is this heights and weight or whatever this look. And it has to act this way. Southern and sassy.
当剧本的人物小传里写得清清楚楚时，大家走进来，很多人都会做出完全相同的选择，因为上面写着某个角色会做某事。我们在找一个30到40岁、身高体重符合标准或者长相如何的人。而且必须这样演。既有南方风情又泼辣。
I think they have to fulfill that instead of just bringing themselves. Bringing their unique quality. Make a choice. Make a choice. And I find myself sometimes like thinking, you know, when I'm reading something now to make sure to make choices that it may be a,
我觉得他们必须去迎合这种设定，而不是展现自我。展现他们独特的品质。做出选择。做出选择。有时我发现自己在想，你知道的，现在我读剧本时，为了确保做出选择……
it may be a wrong choice, but just to have something completely unique that no one else will do. And that you own, that you're able to execute. Yeah. Now, when is the last time you auditioned? Oh man. It's been, I feel like every day is an audition honestly, but it's been, it's been 10 years.
这可能是一个错误的选择，但就是要表现出某种完全独特、别人都不会做的东西。而且你要驾驭它，能够把它演出来。是的。话说，你上一次试镜是什么时候？噢天哪。那是……老实说，我觉得每天都在试镜，但那已经是10年前的事了。
Yeah. I'm going to start making choices like, you know, like imagine like a scene where you got to deliver some bad news, but I'm going to just like, like, well, we just got the report back. It looks like, you're not going to make it. Honestly, no, it's different. It's different.
对。我打算开始做一些选择，比如，你知道的，想象一个你需要传达坏消息的场景，但我会直接说：“嗯，我们刚拿到报告。看起来……你没救了。”老实说，不，这不一样。这不一样。
I used to sing, there's a song from Les Mis. Hold on. That's called empty chairs and empty tables where my friends are dead and gone. And I used to sing it with a huge smile on my face. So wait, Octavia, you said, casting made you want to start acting. You had no interest before that.
我以前唱歌，有一首来自《悲惨世界》的歌。等等。那首歌叫《空椅子和空桌子》，我的朋友们都已死去离去。我以前总是带着满脸灿烂的笑容唱这首歌。等等，奥克塔维亚，你刚才说，选角工作让你萌生了当演员的想法。你之前完全没有兴趣。
And you just got that as a job. Or what was it like as a kid? Well, I'd always wanted to be a producer, honestly. And I love acting, but, you know, I'm from a very practical household. And my mom would have been supportive had I just said, I want to be an actor. But, you know, she really like wanted me to be a doctor
你当时只是把它当成一份工作。或者说你小时候是什么样的？嗯，老实说，我一直想成为一名制片人。我热爱表演，但是，你知道的，我来自一个非常务实的家庭。如果我当时说我想当演员，我妈妈也会支持我的。但是，你知道的，她真的很希望我成为一名医生……
or a lawyer and I'm a germaphobe. So I knew doctoring was not in my future. Because everything anybody came into the room with, I would probably, did I get it? Are you, oh my God. I love catching, so. That's me. Sean's got it.
或者律师，而我有洁癖。所以我知道行医绝对不在我的未来规划里。因为别人带进房间的任何东西，我大概都会……我猜对了吗？你是……噢天哪。我超爱接梗，所以……就是我。肖恩猜对了。
Sean, just got it. Just you describing it. Just describe it and I would get it. Yeah, you are talking to a couple of world-class germaphobes here with me and Sean. Those guys, not me, not me. Yeah, yeah. So Octavia, what's, tell me your,
肖恩猜对了。只要你一描述。只要你描述一下，我马上就能懂。对，你现在是在和两个世界级的洁癖说话，我和肖恩。他们俩可不是，我可不是。对，对。所以，奥克塔维亚，来吧，告诉我你的……
let's open up this germaphobe thing. What is, because I've got an answer for me, we'll go around the horn. What is, what grosses you out the most? What will you not do because there's too much germ potential? I'll start with mine so that you know what I'm kind of talking about. I will never walk barefoot on a hotel floor.
我们来聊聊这个洁癖的话题。什么是——因为我心里有答案，我们挨个说——什么最让你觉得恶心？有什么事因为潜在细菌太多而你绝对不会做？我先说我自己的，这样你知道我在说什么。我绝不会光脚踩在酒店房间的地板上。
Wow, that's good. Ever, never. Oh gosh, I will never go to very famous theme parks. You won't even enter the grounds? I don't think I need to go. Got it. It's aggressive, Octavia. You know, I will never sit on a plane.
哇，这个好。从来不，绝不。噢天哪，我绝不去非常著名的主题公园。你甚至都不会踏入园区一步？我觉得我不需要去。懂了。这很激进，奥克塔维亚。你知道的，我绝不在飞机上坐着……
Nice. Wiping, and I've been doing this for years. Wiping everything down. So definitely the headrest, right? Yep. The headrest, anything that my hand has to touch has to be wiped down. You know, the seat back button,
太棒了。擦拭，而且我这么做好多年了。把所有东西都擦一遍。所以绝对是头枕，对吧？对。头枕，任何我的手必须触碰到的东西都必须擦拭干净。你知道，座椅靠背上的按钮……
you got to really get that one too. Oh yeah, that's a touch point, touch point. I will never, I will never have a Gaspacho soup in October, like after October. No, very, very smart. I won't do it. Not a lot of people know that one. No, no, and even if I'm in the South of France,
那个你真的也得照顾到。噢对，那是接触点，接触点。我绝不会在10月份吃西班牙冷菜汤，比如10月以后。不，非常非常明智。我不会吃的。没多少人知道这一点。不，不，哪怕我在法国南部……
I won't do it, even if it's warm. No, what you got to do is you got to do, because it's cold, so all the bacteria can live. What you got to do is you got to do hot. No, it's just more out of a sense of decency. Now, so I wiped down the plane, I wiped down the planes, the seats too as well. That's kind of a newer thing to me.
我也不会吃，哪怕天气很暖和。不，你要做的是……因为它是冷的，所以所有的细菌都能存活。你要做的是吃热的。不，这更多出于一种体面的感觉。所以，我擦了飞机的内部，把座位也都擦了。这对我来说算是一件比较新的事。
I remember like January, 2020, I flew to London right before the lockdown, and I went back and I looked at my search, we were talking about search history before, I looked at my Amazon order history, and I had ordered masks in January, 2020, I was so nervous about everything coming, that I was seeing on the news,
我记得2020年1月，就在封锁前不久我飞往伦敦，我回去看了一下我的搜索记录——我们之前在聊搜索历史——我看了看我的亚马逊订单历史，我在2020年1月就订购了口罩。我对新闻里看到的各种即将发生的事情感到非常紧张……
and I had to fly to London, and I wiped my area down, and I wore a mask, and everybody looked at me like I was crazy, like look at this nut job, I'm like, I don't give a hell. And we will be right back. Well, I wanna go back to now, you did all of this work before the thing that really catapulted you, which was the help,
而我必须飞往伦敦，我把我的区域擦得干干净净，还戴着口罩，每个人都像看疯子一样看着我，就像在看这个神经病，而我心想：我才不在乎呢。我们马上回来。好吧，我想回到过去，你在真正让你一飞冲天的作品之前做了大量的工作，那就是《帮助》……
which obviously 75 years later, you were amazing, but just incredible. Let us be the first to congratulate you on that. Yeah, exactly. Thank you guys. We've been waiting, you were incredible, you were absolutely incredible though. Sean's right.
显然在75年后，你表现得太惊艳了，简直不可思议。让我们成为第一批向你表示祝贺的人。对，没错。谢谢你们。我们一直在等待，你太棒了，不过你真的太棒了。肖恩说得对。
I love that, I love that movie. Absolutely great. But you did a book tour with the author, Katherine Stockett, is that her name? Yes, yes. And I read that she didn't feel comfortable reading passages from the book when it came to the African-American characters,
我太喜欢了，我太喜欢那部电影了。绝对是佳作。但你和原作者凯瑟琳·斯托科特一起进行了图书巡回宣传，是叫这个名字吗？是的，是的。我读到过，当涉及非裔美国人角色时，她对朗读书中的片段感到很不自在……
so she asked you to come along, and tell me what that was like, and is that how you got the role? Because again, you were again reading, somebody else's words or something. Yes, yeah, well it's very interesting because I met Katherine through Tate and- Tate's the director, yeah.
所以她邀请你一起去，告诉我那是什么样的经历，你是怎么得到这个角色的？因为同样地，你当时又在读……别人的台词之类的。是的，嗯，这非常有趣，因为我是通过泰认识凯瑟琳的，还有……泰是导演，对吧？
Oh, through Tate Taylor who wrote the screenplay and directed the film, who's a personal friend. Katherine, I think the help was starting to like, become like a little wildfire and catch on, and she was very smart in that she knew that it would have been kind of weird to do the dialect. And it was during pilot season guys, and she paid for me.
噢，通过编写剧本并执导这部电影的泰·泰勒，他也是我的私交。凯瑟琳，我觉得《帮助》当时开始像星星之火一样燃起并流行开来，她非常聪明，因为她知道如果由她来模仿方言会显得有点奇怪。当时正值美剧试播季，伙计们，她自掏腰包让我去。
I'm like, normally you don't miss pilot season, but I thought, I love this character, I love this book. And I just said, you know, I'm gonna go do this. And we drove around on her book tour for like three weeks. Wow. And it was like we were the band driving into town. That's so cool. Yeah.
我说，通常你不会错过试播季的，但我想，我爱这个角色，我爱这本书。我当时就说，你知道的，我要去。我们在她的图书巡演车里开了大约三个星期。哇。那感觉就像我们是一支开进小镇的乐队。太酷了。是的。
It was so fun. How unusual that, and how cool. And then, especially considering what it turned into, and then turning into this great film, and to incredible acclaim, what a great piece of that story for you to be able to really be a part of the process so early on. Oh, it was important.
太有趣了。这是多么不同寻常，又多么酷。而且考虑到它后来取得的成就，变成了一部伟大的电影，并赢得了难以置信的赞誉，你能这么早就真正参与到这个故事的进程中，这真是太棒了。噢，这太重要了。
The other thing that people probably don't know is that the help was made into a radio play in the UK. And because of my association with Katherine, and because I had done the book on tape, they asked me if I would come and do the radio play which I'd never done that. And I did. It was very interesting.
另一件人们可能不知道的事是，《帮助》在英国被改编成了广播剧。因为我和凯瑟琳的关系，也因为我录过有声书，他们问我愿不愿意去录广播剧——我以前从来没做过那种事。我去了。这非常有趣。
It was very interesting to do a radio play. That doesn't sound positive. That doesn't sound positive. No, no. Let's hear about that. It was fun. But when all you have is the audio, and people don't get to see you,
录广播剧是非常有趣的体验。听起来不太积极。听起来不太积极。不，不。我们听听是怎么回事。挺有意思的。但当你只有音频，而人们看不到你时……
I was just so used to people seeing me, that I thought, am I going to convey this? So it was like just over exaggerating stuff, and oh man, I... It is a weird thing. Welcome, by the way, welcome to our world. People are so happy that our podcast that they don't have to see us anymore.
我太习惯人们看到我了，以至于我在想：我能传达出这种感觉吗？所以这就像是把东西过度夸张地表现出来，噢天哪，我……这是一件很诡异的事。顺便欢迎来到我们的世界。大家现在高兴得很，因为我们的播客让他们再也不用看到我们了。
It turns out that our audience has been exhilarated to not have to look at us. Well, Octavia, you work so much. What is it that you are not able to do because you're working all the time that you wish you had more time to do that is not acting? I literally, and the one thing that the pandemic made us do is take time,
事实证明，我们的观众对于不用看着我们感到兴奋不已。好吧，奥克塔维亚，你工作太忙了。有什么事是你因为一直在工作而无法去做、但你希望有更多时间去做的非表演的事情吗？我 literalmente，大流行唯一强迫我们做的一件事就是放慢脚步……
but I didn't actually get to take the time that I would have liked to with my family in Alabama. I have nieces and nephews, and I feel with your friends, if you're on the road so much, and I know all of my friends, first children, it's in these past few years that they've had second kids that are growing up and have personalities.
但我实际上并没有抽出我想要的时间去阿拉巴马州陪我的家人。我有侄女和外甥，我觉得如果你一直在路上奔波——我知道我所有的朋友的第一批孩子，都是在过去这几年里生了第二个孩子，他们正在长大并且有了各自的性格。
I feel the same way about my nieces and nephews. So it's making me take time to really just spend more time with my family. Yeah, that's interesting. You do do that. I can identify with that, that idea that your friends have a kid, and you go, that's so great,
我对我的侄女和外甥也有同感。所以这逼着我抽出时间来，真正多花时间陪陪家人。是的，这很有趣。你确实这么做了。我能感同身受，那种朋友有了孩子，然后你觉得“太棒了”，并且你能去了解这个孩子。等他们有了第二个孩子时，你会想：“得了吧，我已经把注意力给了你的老大。你还想怎样？
and you can get to know the kid. And by the time they have the second kid, you're like, yeah, I already gave attention to your first kid. What do you want? Now you want equal? You want me to get equal? I don't have that kind of time.
现在你想要平等的待遇？你想让我一碗水端平？我可没那么多时间。你在说什么呢？”不，等等，但是奥克塔维亚，既然你在洛杉矶住了很多年，你怀念阿拉巴马那种我猜应该是更安静、更简单生活吗？当你退休时——我希望你永远不会退休，但是——你有没有想过自己会回到那里去？嗯，自从我的家人……
What are you talking about? No, wait, but Octavia, now that you've lived in Los Angeles for many years, do you miss the more, I'm guessing what you're saying, like quieter, simple life that was Alabama? And do you ever see yourself going back there when you retire, which I hope you never do, but. Well, I have, since my family's era,
我在那里有个家，但我也在另一个南方州建房子，只是因为我太想念树木了。我想念我的……我想念周围的风景。所以，既然我的朋友们都住在那个非常乡村的地区，那就成了我们的退休世外桃源。太奇怪了。我在那里建了一栋房子……
I have a home there, but I'm also building a home in another Southern state, just because I miss a lot of trees. I miss my, I miss the surroundings. So, since my friends are in this very rural area, it's kind of our retirement enclave. It's so weird. I'm building a house there,
只是为了让我被……我懂。我们拼命逃离的东西，最终正是我们想要跑回去的东西，我很怀念那种感觉。你在逃避什么？嗯，我逃避的是树木。我当时想要更多的建筑和汽车……
just so that I am surrounded by. I get it. What we all run away from is what we run back to eventually, and I miss that. What are you running away from? Well, I ran away from trees. I wanted more buildings and cars,
而现在我觉得：“我想要树木。”是的，是的。肖恩，你在逃避什么？我自己，无论我走到哪里。懂了。这就是为什么你把家里所有的镜子都拆了吗？对。是的，你不知道这事吗？
and now I was like, I want trees. Yeah, yeah. Sean, what are you running away from? Myself, everywhere I go. Got it. Is that why you've removed all the mirrors in your house? Yeah. Yeah, did you not know that well?
不知道。全拆了。我想聊聊去参加奥斯卡的事。那么当你去的时候，《帮助》是你第一次去奥斯卡吗？是的。是的，而且你获奖了，这太棒了。你第一次到那里时是什么感觉？
No. Took them all out. I want to talk about going to the Oscars. So when you went to, was the help the first time you went to the Oscars? Yes. Yeah, and you won, which is great. And what was it like when you first got there?
比如，有些人已经去过好多次了，你第一次去时，是如何看待这一切并将它全部吸收、环顾四周的？你注意到有什么有趣的事情吗？比如“他们这样做真奇怪”或者“我不知道他们会这样做”之类的事情。你知道什么让人真正感到平静和美妙吗？
Like, there are people who have gone so many times, and what was your perspective of the first time you went there and drank it all in and looked around? Was there anything funny about it that you noticed? Like, that's so weird that they do that, or I didn't know they did that, or anything like that. You know what was really calming and wonderful
那就是我能和我的老朋友之一梅丽莎·麦卡西一起受邀参加奥斯卡。杰西卡·查斯坦也成了我的密友。还有吉姆·拉什和纳特·法克森，我是通过格罗林认识他们的。吉姆·拉什太棒了。我爱吉姆。我爱那几个家伙。
is that I got to be invited to the Oscars along with one of my oldest friends, Melissa McCarthy. And Jessica Chastain had become a very close friend. And then Jim Rash and Nat Fax, and I knew them through the growling. Jim Rash is the best. I love Jim. I love those guys.
还有纳特。肖恩，你不喜欢纳特·法克森。不，我都爱。不，我们懂了。你接着说。我爱吉姆和纳特。这两个人我都非常喜欢。我这是有公开记录的。
And Nat. Sean, you don't like Nat Fax. No, I love them all. No, we got it. Go ahead. I love Jim and Nat. I like both of those guys a lot. I'm on the record.
我有公开记录说过我同样爱他们俩。好吧，我们一起去了。这真的很重要，因为它让一切都保持真实。而且很有趣。我们互相看到时都会说：“天哪，他们居然让我们进来了。”所以当时就是：你敢相信吗？噢，天哪。但这让它变得非常有共鸣……
I'm on the record of saying I love both of them equally. Well, we got to go together. And it was just important because it kept it all real. And it was funny. We'd all see each other and go, oh my God, they let us in. So it was, can you believe it? Oh, man. But it made it so relatable
因为那是我们所有人的梦想。而且我们能一起在那里经历这一切。后来我很幸运，见证了艾莉森·珍妮获奖，看到埃玛再次获得提名。见证了维奥拉再次获奖。见证了杰西卡再次获得提名。所以我觉得……见证了梅丽莎再次获得提名。当能够与你爱的人以及爱你的人共同经历、拥有这种体验时……
because it was all of our dreams. And we got to be there to experience it with each other. And then I've been lucky enough to be there when Allison Janney won and got to see Emma nominated again. Got to be there when Viola won again. Got to be there when Jessica was nominated again. And so I felt got to be there when Melissa was nominated again. There's something really wonderful
有一种非常美妙的感觉。它消解了那种宏大感和铺天盖地的兴奋。是的。这很美妙，但又让人感到谦卑。对。你对整个红毯仪式有什么看法？
when you get to take that, have that experience with other people that you love and that love you. And it takes some of that grandeur and the overwhelming excitement. Yeah. It's wonderful, but it's humbling. Right. What did you think about the whole red carpet of it all?
那片摄影师的海洋……人们不了解我的一点是——这是一个巨大的爆料——我非常……我至今仍然有焦虑症。我对走红毯真的感到很焦虑。我喜欢盛装打扮，我喜欢做采访，但我不喜欢一边做采访、一边盛装打扮……
That sea of photographers and... The thing that people don't know about me, this is a huge reveal. I have huge and I still have anxiety. I have real anxiety about red carpets. I love to dress up. I love to do interviews, but I don't like to do interviews and dress up
周围还有闪光灯和一大群人。所以每次你在红毯上看到我，总是会有这样一种……她会想：为什么她一直在出汗？那是因为我 literalmente 感到焦虑。所以当你想象世界上最长的红毯时……
and have flashing cameras and a big throng of people. So every time you see me on a red carpet, there's always like this. She's like, why is she always shining? It's because I like literally have anxiety. So when you imagine the longest red carpet in the world. Yeah. It just goes on forever.
对。它简直没完没了。但我的意思是，这是一件非常诡异的事情……我记得《发展受阻》剧组去参加——我想是金球奖，这是我们去的第一场活动，对吧？然后我记得迈克尔·塞拉以前从来没去过红毯活动。他一直在对我们其中的几个人说：“那么，我们该做些什么？
But I mean, it's a really odd thing to... I remember the arrest of development went to, I think it was the Golden Globes is the first thing that we went to, right? Well, and I remember Michael Sarah had never been to a red carpet thing. And he was like, he had been saying to a couple of us, like, so what do we do?
是一直往前走吗？”我想我当时说：“不，不，不，你走过去，停下来，他们给你拍几张照片。然后再走，停下来，他们再拍几张。”他说：“好吧。那怎么知道该看哪台相机呢？”你只要四处转动一下眼睛就行了。他说：“好吧，好的。”
Do you just keep walking? And I think I was like, no, no, no, you walk and you stop and they take some pictures of you. And then you walk again and stop and they take some pictures. He goes, okay. And like, how do you figure out which camera to look at? You just keep kind of moving your eyes around a little bit. He's like, okay, good.
所以在几天后，我们去了现场，他正排队等待走红毯。而排在他前面的是……等等，别剧透，别剧透，别剧透，别剧透。我没有……我能说完吗？因为你快要把……噢，是吗？你继续。
So a couple of days later we go and he's waiting his turn to go walk on the red carpet. And in front of him is... Wait, don't blow it, don't blow it, don't blow it, don't blow it. I'm not... Can I just finish? Cause you're about to blow the... Oh, am I? Go ahead.
我们听听，威尔。你。所以，你差点说出那个名字。他在那儿走着，然后他说……那是笑话的一部分，不过你接着说。他们当时在喊——迈克尔？不，不，这个……他们当时在喊……
Let's hear it, Will. You. So, you almost mentioned the name. He's walking there and he said... That's part of the joke, but let's go ahead. They were going Michael? No, no, this... They were going...
不，你把顺序说反了。好吧，你来。我跟你说，你来。所以排在他前面的是萨拉·杰西卡·帕克，排在他后面的是迈克尔·道格拉斯。所以他们一边走，别人一边喊：“迈克尔，萨拉，迈克尔，萨拉。”而他根本不知道该看哪边。
No, you're doing it backwards. Okay, you go ahead. I'm telling you, go ahead. So in front of him is Sarah Jessica Parker and behind of him is Michael Douglas. And so they're walking along and they're going, Michael, Sarah, Michael, Sarah. And he had no idea which way to look.
所以，威尔，如果是你来讲，你会说……你把笑话的顺序讲反了。他一边走一边对自己说：“听到叫你名字的时候一直往前走就行了。”然后他一直听到别人在喊：“迈克尔，萨拉。”他心里想：“噢天哪，这太不可思议了，迈克尔，萨拉。”然后他看了看自己的两侧。
So, Will, in your telling, you would say... You're telling the joke backwards. He's walking along and he says, just keep going as they call your name. And he keeps hearing them go, Michael, Sarah. And he's thinking, oh my God, this is incredible. Michael, Sarah. And then he looks on either side of him.
一边是迈克尔·道格拉斯，另一边是萨拉·杰西卡·帕克。笑话是这么讲的。这样好多了。我们进个广告吧。因为刚才真是操蛋的尴尬。我们去放个该死的广告吧。我们喘口气。
One side is Michael Douglas, the other side is Sarah Jessica Parker. That's how you tell a joke. That's better. Let's go to a commercial. Because that was fucking embarrassing. Let's go to a fucking commercial. We'll take a breath.
你说得对。你说得对，你说得对，你说得对。威尔？威尔？你说得对。嘿，很高兴能来到杰森在演艺圈的第一天。这太有趣了。这就是为什么我不写剧本，你知道的？当你遇到像《帮助》这样重大的作品……
You're right. You're right, you're right. Will? Will? You're right. Hey, it's great to be here on Jason's first day in Showbiz. This is fun. This is why I don't write, you know? When you have something as big as the help
然后你开始接到各种邀约，你的职业生涯开始风生水起、越做越大。人们开始注意到你真正的才华。你被邀请进入那种地位。好吧，看看威尔。怎么了？杰森懂的。
and then you start getting offers and your career starts opening up and getting bigger and bigger. And people are noticing how talented you really are. And you're invited into that kind of status. Well, look at Will. What's going on? Jason knows.
他只是因为自己猜对了而得意洋洋。他太喜欢正确的感觉了。而你现在进入了这样一个行列，为了不用更粗俗的词，作为一个演员，你被赋予了合法性。你以前也是，但不知何故，现在业内的人对你的看法不同了。你……合法化。
He's just all pumped up because he was right. He loves being right. And you're now in this league of, you know, for lack of a grosser word, legitimized as an actor. You were before, but for some reason, people see you differently in this business now. And do you- Legitimated.
什么？正确的词是“被合法化”。对，合法化。我只是想证明自己是对的。我只是会继续说下去，然后继续犯错。你接着说。你现在必须合法化。你现在必须应付更艰难的决定……
What's that? The correct word is legitimated. Yeah, legitimated. I'm just gonna try to be right. I'm just gonna keep going and keep being wrong. Go ahead. You have to now legitimize. You have to now navigate making more difficult decisions
比如经纪人团队的选择、交易的达成。这里面有商业的一面。你把所有的经纪人都解雇了吗？不，我不是那个意思。你是如何在这条阶梯上往上爬的？你知道吗？我非常幸运，因为绝大多数一直陪伴我的人……
as far as representatives, deal making. There's the business side of that. Did you fire all your agents? No, that's not what I meant. How do you navigate up that ladder? You know what? I've been very fortunate in that the majority of the people that are with me
从我默默无闻到——你知道的，有些人知道我的名字——这段旅程的一开始，他们就一直陪着我。所以我感觉自己得到了很好的指导，并没有觉得需要更换他们，因为他们了解我，知道哪些事能让我兴奋，知道我在哪些地方表现得太保守、需要突破自我并挑战自己。
have been with me since the beginning of this whole journey from obscurity to, you know, people, some people know my name. And so I feel like I've had good guidance and have not felt the need because they know me and they know the things that excite me, the things that I am too safe with that I need to push beyond and challenge myself.
噢天哪，我现在就在做这种事。唱歌跳舞。真的吗？对。你现在在演音乐剧？我在演音乐剧，伙计们。你是在和威尔、瑞恩一起拍那部电影吗？是的。
Oh God, I'm doing that right now. Singing and dancing. Really? Yeah. You're doing a musical right now? I'm doing a musical, guys. Are you doing the movie with Will and Ryan? Yes.
噢天哪。太棒了。我们应该直接去波士顿，因为他们都在那边。我们 literally 采访过那部戏里的所有人。对，我知道。我们下周直接去那儿吧。你们应该一起来，伙计们。那是和肖恩·安德斯合作的，我的意思是……
Oh my God. That's great. We should just go to Boston because they're all up there. We've literally interviewed everybody in that show. Yeah, I know. Let's just go up there next week. You should come, guys. And it's with Sean Anders, I mean,
他担任导演，我只是觉得自己非常幸运，我没有沦为昙花一现的演员，而是凭借《帮助》功成身退、达到事业巅峰，原因是我拥有极佳的合作伙伴和经纪团队。梅丽莎、凯特和Viewpoint的所有人。我的意思是，我只是……我觉得我们的公关团队以及这种指导一直都在，他们懂我。
directing and I just feel very lucky that the reason I am not a one hit wonder and went out on a high note with the help is that I have wonderful partnerships and representation. Melissa, Kate's and everybody at viewpoint. I mean, I've just, I feel like our publicists, and I feel like the guidance is there and they understand me.
所以我感到非常幸运。太棒了。是的，你一定有这种感觉。我觉得你得到了所有的关注。肖恩什么都没有。是这样吗？因为我就会那样做。如果我是你的公关，我会把所有的聚光灯都给你。
So I feel very lucky. That's great. Yeah, you must feel. And I feel like you get all the attention. Sean doesn't get anything. Is that right? Cause I would do that. If I was your publicist, I would give it all to you.
我所有的媒体曝光都给了奥克塔维亚。然后我会假装看手机，说：“噢，是肖恩。喂，怎么了？喂，有什么事吗？”我们经常被认错，肖恩。经常。我要是一美元……
All of my press goes to Octavia. And then I'd be like, and I'd be looking at my phone. I'd be like, oh, it's Sean. Hey, what? Hey, what's up? We're mistaken for each other, Sean. All the time. I had a dollar.
所以，你一直想要却没能得到的角色是什么？有没有哪个角色是你去试镜了、或者听说可能会给你演但最后没拿到手的？噢亲爱的，这绝对是……我一直对凯文·科斯特纳着迷。我……他是那种我看过他所有作品的演员。
So what is the role that you've always wanted that you didn't get? Is there a part that you auditioned for or you heard that was maybe gonna be offered, but you didn't get it? Oh honey, this is the absolute. I have always been obsessed with Kevin Costner. I, he's one of those actors
我在好莱坞演过太多护士了，当时他拍过一部电影叫《蜻蜓》。里面有个角色是个护士，他演一个医生，他的妻子在国外遇害了，他不得不回去找回她的遗体，结果发现自己居然有一个……
that I've seen everything he's done. And I had played so many nurses in Hollywood that there was a movie that he did called Dragonfly. And there was a nurse, he was a doctor and his wife was killed in a foreign country and he had to go, he was going back to get her remains and found out that he literally had a child
连自己都不知道的孩子。这太棒了。他们让我回去试镜了好多次，去演那个和凯文有对手戏的护士。那大概是我第五次去之后——我有画面了，我有画面了。老实说，我以前以为在那些恐怖电影里，当人们极度恐惧或焦虑时……
that he didn't know about. And it was so amazing. And they brought me back so many times to play his nurse who had all these things with Kevin. And it was after like the fifth time I think, I have it, I have it. I honestly thought in those horror films when people are so afraid or they're so angst-ridden
他们会在淋浴间里，因为太难过而哭泣并顺着淋浴间的后墙滑坐到地上。好了，好了。当我发现自己没拿到那个角色时，我心想：“我没事，我没事，我去洗个澡。”当我站在淋浴间里时，我就顺着后墙滑坐了下去。而把我拉回现实的是，伙计们……
that they're in the shower and they're just so upset that they cry and slide down the back of the shower. All right, all right. That when I found out I didn't get that part, I was like, I'm okay, I'm okay, I take a shower. And as I'm in the shower, I just slide down the back wall. And what pulled me out of it, guys,
把我拉回现实的是，我的毛巾卡在下水口里了，水 literalmente 漫了上来，这把我从情绪中猛地惊醒，因为它快要溢出来了。你简直是卡伦·西尔克伍德附体。你知道的，我曾经去试镜过，我和凯文·科斯特纳有过一次复试。我记得多年前跟你们说过这个……
what pulled me out of it is that my towel got stuck in the drain and literally the water was rising up and it snapped me out of it because it was about to overflow. You went full Karen Silkwood. You know, one time I auditioned, I had a callback with Kevin Costner. I remember telling you guys this years ago
把我从那种状态中拉出来的是，我的毛巾卡在了下水道口里，水真的涨了上来，这一下子把我惊醒了，因为水快要溢出来了。你简直就像凯伦·丝克活一样。你知道吗，有一次我参加试镜，我和凯文·科斯特纳有一次回调面试。我记得多年前我跟你们说过这个
and I was in New York for that movie, did it called The Postman. And so the night before I'd gone for some sushi. So you're a little puffy. And no, well, that was the least of my problems with back then. And so I get home about three a.m. I wake up and I am throwing and going.
我当时在纽约拍那部电影，叫《邮差》。那天前一晚我去吃了寿司。所以脸有点浮肿。不，那其实是我当时最不值一提的问题。大约凌晨三点我回到家。我醒来就开始狂吐不止。
And it's just everything and I'm in batch. I ended up going to the hospital. Now you are losing water weight. Sorry, keep going. Now I'm losing, Jason's looking at the glass being half full. He's like, lucky, oh, lucky. So I ended up going to NYU Medical Center and they put me on a bag and put me on a bag.
可以说是翻江倒海，我当时在床上。最后我进了医院。现在你在脱水。抱歉，你继续。现在我在失水，杰森把杯子看成是半满的。他觉得，太好了，太幸运了。所以我最后去了纽约大学医学中心，他们给我挂上了盐水，给我挂上了盐水。
A sodium drip and now you're gaining water weight. Keep going. So I'm just like barely keeping together, but I've got this huge callback at the Essex House Hotel on Central Park South in New York. And I go up there and I remember it was like the dead of, like the middle of summer is super hot. I'm sweating and I'm like,
一瓶钠点滴，现在你开始补充水分了。你继续。所以我整个人简直快撑不住了，但我在纽约中央公园南侧的埃塞克斯大酒店有一个非常重要的复试。我上去了，我记得当时正是三伏天，盛夏酷暑，天气热得要命。我在流汗，我想，
I can't be more than five feet from the bathroom at this point. And I got, so I come in to talk to Kevin Costner and I sit down really gingerly. Sure. Oh, you're sore. I'm sore and there's more coming in. I'm like, nice to meet you.
这时候我离洗手间绝对不能超过五英尺。然后我进去了，去跟凯文·科斯特纳谈话，我非常小心翼翼地坐下。当然。哦，你浑身酸痛。我浑身酸痛，而且还有更多状况要来。我说，很高兴认识你。
I'm really excited. And he's like, okay, let's see when we start to read. And he goes, let's get this on in speed, huh? And I'm thinking, oh, oh, Jesus. Oh, Kevin, I've torn something. Just don't, don't shit yourself in front of Kevin Costner. Don't shit yourself in front of Kevin Costner. Did you get through it?
我真的很兴奋。他说，好吧，那我们开始对词吧。接着他说，我们这就开始吧，开始进入状态，哈？我心里想，哦，哦，天哪。哦，凯文，我好像拉伤了什么地方。千万别，千万别在凯文·科斯特纳面前拉裤子。千万别在凯文·科斯特纳面前拉裤子。你挺过来了吗？
I barely, I barely, I got through it. It was terrible because I was just, I was a wreck and I'd been up all night. I'd been in the hospital. I was sweating. Nice to meet you. And of course I did not get the part. Good luck with the project, guys.
我勉强，勉强挺过来了。太糟糕了，因为我整个人彻底崩溃了，而且我一宿没睡。我刚去过医院。我在流汗。很高兴认识你。当然啦，我没拿到这个角色。祝你们的项目一切顺利，伙计们。
Yeah. Anyway, Kevin, if you're out there, I love you, buddy. And now, back to the show. Octavia, how did the Kevin fascination start? What hooked you? I think the first thing that I ever saw of his was dances with wolves. Sure.
对。不管怎样，凯文，如果你能听到的话，我爱你，老兄。现在，我们回到节目中。奥克塔维亚，你对凯文的迷恋是怎么开始的？是什么吸引了你？我想我第一次看他的作品是《与狼共舞》。当然。
And the fact that he wore all those hats and it was so... John Dunbar. John Dunbar. John Dunbar. John Dunbar. Yeah, that'll do it. Oh man, I just love that movie.
还有他戴着各种帽子，而且那种…… 约翰·邓巴。 约翰·邓巴。 约翰·邓巴。 约翰·邓巴。 对，这就足够了。天哪，我太喜欢那部电影了。
And then, you know, he's gorgeous. And to get to meet him, he's such a, he's a good guy. So, but I, you know, it's when you meet a person that moves you and you're like, oh my God, I got to see everything. Wait, wasn't he in Hidden Figures? He was in Hidden Figures. And he and I also...
然后呢，你知道的，他帅呆了。而且能见到他本人，他真的是个很好的人。所以，但是我知道，当你遇到一个能打动你的人，你就会想，哦天哪，我得看遍他的所有作品。等等，他不是演了《隐藏人物》吗？他演了《隐藏人物》。而且我和他……
You got to work with him. I got to work with him twice. We did a movie together called Black or White. And... Oh yeah, wait, that's Mike Binder's movie. Mike Binder, yeah. Yeah, he's a friend of the court. Does Kevin know that you're a security risk?
你有机会跟他合作。我有过两次跟他的合作机会。我们一起拍过一部叫《黑白父女》的电影。还有…… 哦对，等等，那是迈克·宾德的电影。迈克·宾德，对。对，他是自己人。凯文知道你是个安全隐患吗？
Well, I tried to keep that from him. But let me tell you, when I got the call to do Black or White, I was driving from Beverly Hills. And I'm the worst driver guys anyway. But I'm driving and they're like, he and I had the same agent at the time. And he was calling to tell me about, you know, the role and offer me the role and Black or White.
嗯，我尽量向他隐瞒这一点。但我得告诉你，当我接到电话去拍《黑白父女》时，我正开车行驶在比弗利山庄。反正我本来就是个烂司机。但我开着车，他们就——当时我和他用的是同一个经纪人。他打电话来是想告诉我关于那个角色以及邀请我出演《黑白父女》。
And I'm thinking, oh yeah, yeah, Kevin Costner's gonna call me. I'm driving and all of a sudden, you know, my phone rings and it's not a phone number. I recognize, I pick up and it's like Octavia's Kevin. I'm like, oh God, oh my God, God's great. Because I'm about to lose signal. I pull over like, you know, it was so crazy.
我当时心想，哦对，对，凯文·科斯特纳会打电话给我。我正在开车，突然间，你知道的，我的电话响了，那不是一个我认识的号码。我接起来，对方说我是凯文。我说，哦天哪，哦天哪，上帝真好。因为我快要没信号了。我赶紧把车停在路边，你知道的，当时太疯狂了。
But he's still, he's a good, it was just fun to get to work with him. And because... The man has some presence, doesn't he? He definitely does. And he is, he's the definition of classically handsome too, isn't he? He's classically handsome and classically generous too, guys.
但他依然是个好人，能跟他合作真的很有趣。因为…… 这男人真有气场，不是吗？他绝对有。而且他，他也绝对称得上是标准的大帅哥，对吧？他不仅是标准的大帅哥，而且也同样非常慷慨大方，伙计们。
Yeah, I love that. Very generous, yeah. I love that, I love that. Now, is it true Octavia, are you the, I'm gonna get this right or wrong. Are you the most nominated African-American actress of all time? No, I think that would be Viola Davis this year with,
对，我太喜欢这点了。非常慷慨，是的。我太喜欢了，我太喜欢了。那么，奥克塔维亚，这是真的吗，你是——我可别说错了。你是历史上获得提名最多的非裔美国女演员吗？不，我想今年应该是维奥拉·戴维斯，凭借着，
oh God. Did she just surpass you? So it was until this year? Uh-huh. Now, I think she and I were tied. We were tied. That's pretty awesome. Yeah, yeah, she's... That's pretty great.
哦天哪。她刚刚超过你了吗？所以直到今年之前都是你？嗯哼。现在，我想我和她并列。我们并列第一。这太厉害了。对，对，她…… 这太棒了。
Yeah, no kidding. She's amazing. That's crazy, that's crazy. The most nominated, that's incredible. Well, now you get another one for the singing and the dancing too, you know? Oh honey, I would just love, like my scalp is the only thing
真的假的。她太惊艳了。太疯狂了，太疯狂了。获得最多提名，这太不可思议了。好吧，现在你因为唱歌跳舞又要得一个提名了，你知道吗？哦亲爱的，我只能说，我身上唯一在出汗和减肥的地方
that's sweating and losing weight. It's the thinnest thing on the body. All this dancing, I'm like, come on, God. Look at what you're doing. Yeah, what's the dancing like? Is that, so what's, did you have to train for it before you guys started? Are you training right now?
就是我的头皮。那是身上最瘦的部位。跳了这么多舞，我都想说，拜托了，上帝。看看你都在做些什么。对啊，跳舞是怎么样的？那是，所以那是怎样的？你们开始之前必须进行训练吗？你现在在训练吗？
Like what's that like? I'm training right now. I'm just trying to keep it all flowing. It's just not, my body, I don't have rhythm. And, you know, just, you know, moving from here to like right there. And I'm pointing maybe a foot away or like, you know, I can do it, you know?
那是什么感觉？我现在正在训练。我只是在努力让一切动作连贯起来。就是不行，我的身体，我没有节奏感。而且，你知道的，就是从这里移动到那个地方。可能指向一英尺远的地方，或者像，你知道的，我能做到，你知道吗？
But I, all of the, I just don't have that kind of movement and to do it and sing at the same time is challenging, but really, really fun. How are you dealing with that nasty prick, Ryan Reynolds? He's just, he's a nasty piece of business. Yeah, he just must just wreck the vibe on the set. And he's not a friend, he's not a friend of the show. The worst reputation.
但我，所有的那些，我就是没有那种律动，要在边跳边唱的同时做到这一点极具挑战，但真的，真的很有趣。你怎么对付那个讨厌的混蛋瑞安·雷诺兹？他简直是个讨嫌的家伙。对啊，他肯定把片场的氛围全搞砸了。而且他可不是朋友，他不是节目的朋友。名声臭极了。
And that negative, that negative Will Ferrell. I mean, oh, she's always so, you know, come on, turn it upside down. Let's turn it into a smile. I would say this, and I reserve this for only a few people, but Will Ferrell is a great A-hole. Yeah, we'll cut that out, but yeah. I'm not gonna tell him you said that.
还有那个消极的，那个消极的威尔·法瑞尔。我是说，哦，她总是那么，你知道的，拜托，振作点。让我们把它变成一个微笑。我要这么说，而且我只把这评价留给极少数人，但威尔·法瑞尔绝对是个绝顶的大混蛋。对，我们会把这段剪掉的，但对。我可不会告诉他你这么说过。
I don't want to start none, and I don't want him to be. Because he's also very violent. A lot of people don't know how violent he is. He's a very, make a clip of it, and I want to mail it to his house. Yeah. But you're gonna get through it. You'll get through it, Octavia.
我不想惹事生非，也不想让他变成。因为他其实也很暴力。很多人都不知道他有多暴力。他非常——剪辑个片段出来，我要寄到他家去。对。但你能挺过去的。你能挺过去的，奥克塔维亚。
I'm gonna deny all aspects of this, guys, because, you know. Octavia, so what I want to ask you is, so you mentioned Jim Rash and Nat Faxen, and of course, Melissa and all these groundlings. So forgive me, were you a groundling? Was that, did you start in sketch comedy? No, I took classes at the groundlings, but I would go because Tate Taylor,
我将否认这一切，伙计们，因为，你知道的。奥克塔维亚，我想问你的是，你提到了吉姆·拉什和纳特·法克森，当然还有梅丽莎和所有这些“地面lings”剧团的人。原谅我，你是“地面学校”出来的吗？那是，你是不是从即兴喜剧开始的？不，我在“地面学校”上过课，但我会去那儿是因为泰特·泰勒，
he did go through the whole four years, and I met Ben and Melissa and Nat, all of those guys. I would go and watch them, you know, every Sunday. Right, of course. And it was the best, and so we all became friends. Were your friends with Dax too? Dax, I got to be Dax. It's funny, it's a small world.
他确实上完了整整四年的课程，我遇到了本、梅丽莎和纳特，还有所有那些人。我每周日都会去看他们演出，你知道的。没错，当然。那是最好的时光，所以我们都成了朋友。你和达克斯也是朋友吗？达克斯，我和达克斯很熟。真有趣，世界真小。
I know, it's so small, so, so small. So you seem to be living the dream of doing everything you've always wanted. You're constantly working, which is like, oh my God, this is happening. I'm an actor, I've always wanted to be an actor. Not am I only an actor now, but I'm like one of the most famous actors on the planet,
我知道，太小了，太小太小了。所以你似乎在过着梦想中的生活，做着你一直想做的事。你一直在工作，那种感觉就像是，哦天哪，这一切真的发生了。我是一名演员，我一直想成为一名演员。现在我不但成了一名演员，而且我还成了地球上最著名的演员之一，
and what do you do to balance yourself out so it's not all work all the time, or is that really, what makes you happy? And by the way, Sean's looking for a roadmap because he doesn't do anything other than work, so this is more like a suggestion for him. Please help me. I'm a bit of a workaholic, and I'm trying to not be.
你平时是怎么调节平衡的，好让生活不至于全都是工作，还是说，究竟是什么能让你感到快乐？顺便说一句，肖恩正在寻找一份人生指南，因为他除了工作什么都不做，所以这更像是给他的一个建议。请帮帮我吧。我有点工作狂倾向，我正努力改掉这一点。
I'm trying to pump those breaks because when people say it's been 10 years since the help, and I'm like it's been 10 years, I've been doing this for, at that pace for that long, it's a little terrifying. But I think that's the, I don't think, I know that's one of the life lessons that I learned during the pandemic to be able to, to make sure that I have a work-life balance.
我正试着踩刹车，因为当人们说距离《帮助》上映已经过去10年了，而我的反应是：已经10年了吗？我以那种节奏工作了那么久，这多多少少有点吓人。但我认为那是——我不认为，我知道那是我在疫情期间学到的人生教训之一，那就是要确保自己拥有工作与生活的平衡。
Because I really love working, I just love it. Yeah, yeah, I get it. But life is also important. But do you travel and stuff? Like do you go like, I'm gonna finish this job, and I'm gonna take time, and I'm gonna go to Europe, or whatever, like is that your thing? Well, you know what's funny is I always say,
因为我真的很喜欢工作，我就是爱工作。对，对，我懂。但生活同样重要。不过你会去旅游之类的吗？比如你会不会想：我要结束这份工作，然后我要花时间去欧洲，诸如此类的，那是你的风格吗？嗯，你知道最搞笑的是我总是说，
I'm gonna take, after this, I'm gonna go take some time to travel. And then, and I always make this declaration, I'm done working after this guys, after this job, I'm done working for the year. And then someone comes along with a great project, and you're like, well, you know, and so the next thing you know,
等干完这个，我要花点时间去旅游。然后，我总是信誓旦旦地宣布：伙计们，干完这个活儿我就不干了，做完这个项目我今年就收工了。结果接着就会有人带着一个超棒的项目找上门来，你就想，好吧，你知道的，然后一转眼，
another nine months has passed. And so that's been the situation quite honestly. But that's one of the reasons why I'm making sure to get back to my roots and see some trees and some grass growing and go to friends' houses and hang out, it's just important to do that. And does it matter to you whether it's comedy or drama? Do you like being funny or serious more?
又是九个月过去了。老实说，情况一直都是这样。但这正是我为什么要确保回归初心、去看看树木和生长的小草、去朋友家串门的原因之一，做这些事情真的很重要。这对你来说喜剧和戏剧重要吗？你更喜欢搞笑还是严肃？
Let me tell you something, you guys are comedic geniuses and you make it look really, really easy. Comedy is much more difficult than drama to me. And so my hat is off to people who can move through both worlds. But I like learning the world of comedy and getting to watch people. Jay said, I'm telling you, it was such an honor
我得告诉你，你们俩都是喜剧天才，而且你们把这演得非常、非常轻松。在我看来，喜剧比戏剧难得多。所以我对那些能在两个世界里游刃有余的人致以敬意。但我喜欢探索喜剧的世界并观察人们。杰森，我跟你说，这真的是一种荣幸，
because I think you're one of those people who you can do everything. And to get to watch you effortlessly do comedy. Well, no, listen honey, this is not anything that I've not said behind your back. I think we're gonna cut this. I think we're gonna cut all of this out. Yeah, we're not gonna let this go out.
因为我觉得你是那种什么都能演的人。而且能看着你毫不费力地表演喜剧。不，听着，亲爱的，这话我可没少在你背后说。我觉得我们得把这剪了。我觉得我们得把这些全剪掉。对，我们不会把这播出去的。
Just watching you in your element, I learned so much. You never overplayed. You look past the Crab Arms. Those Crab Arms were delicious. They were delicious. It's just such a beautifully cooked. Oh yeah, you had Crab Arms in that film. Yeah, my character was pissed off about it.
光是看着你在自己的舒适区里表演，我就学到了那么多。你从不表演过度。你看着“蟹钳手臂”。那些“蟹钳手臂”太美味了。它们太美味了。简直是烹制得完美无缺。哦对，你在那部电影里长了蟹钳手臂。对，我的角色为此气得要死。
How could you get a superhero power and it'd be Crab Arms? It'd be Crab Arms, it was the best. It may be hungry though, it may be hungry all the time. That's very sweet. We all feel the same way about each other, actually. All four of us on today's show, yeah? Yeah, you guys are brilliant. It's a lot of love, it's a lot of love.
你怎么会获得超能力，结果却是一对蟹钳手臂呢？竟然是蟹钳手臂，这太棒了。不过这可能会让人饿，可能会随时觉得饿。这太甜了。其实我们对彼此都有同感。今天节目的我们四个人，对吧？对，你们太才华横溢了。充满了爱，充满了爱。
Octavia, and then- Oh yes, yes, sorry, yes, yes. All this, with all that's going on, thank you for taking an hour out of your busy schedule to be here with us today. Very nice. It's an honor and I, it was so hard for me to not reveal that I was on early.
奥克塔维亚，然后——哦，是的，是的，抱歉，是的，是的。在这一切百忙之中，谢谢你今天抽出宝贵的一个小时来和我们在一起。太好了。这是我的荣幸，而且，我刚才憋得好辛苦，差点没忍住暴露我早就在线了。
And I don't know if you guys heard me giggling in the background while you're in your opening and was like, oh God, I'm gonna spoil this. Thank you. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Please, please, please tell Ryan and Will and Sean to stick it in their ass for us. Yeah, I will.
我不知道你们听到我在后台咯咯笑没有，当时你们在开场，我心里想，天哪，我要把这给剧透了。谢谢。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。请，请，请代我们转告瑞安、威尔和肖恩让他们吃瘪去吧。好的，我会的。
Thank you. And if they laugh, keep it dead fancied, they mean it. They mean it. I'm gonna sell it guys, I'm gonna sell it too. I love you much. Thank you Octavia, what a pleasure to meet you. Thank you so, so much. God bless you guys and take care.
谢谢。如果他们笑了，就当是他们认真的，他们是认真的。我会把它卖出去的，伙计们，我也要把它卖出去。我非常爱你们。谢谢你，奥克塔维亚，认识你真是太荣幸了。非常非常感谢。上帝保佑你们，保佑你们。
Bless you too. Thanks Octavia, bye. Bye. Bye. She did the, she did the laptop shut. Yeah. She's only the second one that's done that. Second one.
也保佑你。谢谢奥克塔维亚，再见。再见。再见。她做了那个，她做了合上笔记本的动作。对。她是第二个这么做的人。第二个。
Best way to do it. It's a nice having you and a pleasant goodbye. Yeah. And then just shut it. Yeah, it's like she's a little pearl in an oyster shell and she just closes it back up. It doesn't feel the need to like hang around after and go like, hey guys, yeah, that's great.
最好的告别方式。这样既有面子又道别得很愉快。对。然后直接合上。对，就像她是一只生蚝里的珍珠，然后又把壳合上了。完全不需要在结束之后还留在那里寒暄说，嘿，伙计们，太棒了。
I was glad that I was able to introduce you to my talk show character and then now we can say bye for real. All right, no, no. Which is why, I always liked about Letterman because you do Letterman. What the fuck am I looking at right now? Sorry, I took my shoe off for a second.
我很高兴能向你们展示我脱口秀嘉宾的人设，现在我们可以真正说再见了。好吧，不，不。这就是为什么，我一直很喜欢大卫·莱特曼，因为你上莱特曼的节目。我特么现在在看什么鬼东西？抱歉，我把鞋脱了一会儿。
It's my van. It's one of his shoes, it's a van shoe. And I was just making a point that, you know, when you go to Letterman, he didn't do a lot of, wasn't a lot of small talk. Not a lot of commercial chitchat, yeah. Yeah, the commercial chitchat was. Yeah, when you go to commercial, yeah, Dave.
这是我的万斯鞋。是他的鞋之一，一双万斯鞋。我刚才只是想说明，你知道的，当你去上莱特曼的节目时，他不会有很多废话，没有什么太多的闲聊。没什么广告期间的闲聊，对。对，广告期间的闲聊。对，当进广告时，是的，戴夫。
Carson would light up a cigarette. He'd sit there, light up a cigarette and watch Doc play in the band. Really? Right in his seat there. Yeah, yeah, during the commercial break. Right on the stage. Yeah, just fire up a butt.
强尼·卡森会点上一支烟。他就坐在那儿，点上一支烟，看着多克在乐队里演奏。真的吗？就在他那座位上。对，对，在广告休息期间。就在舞台上。对，直接点上一根。
No way. When I was, when I first moved to LA and I went to a taping of Jay Leno, I was shocked, I was wondered what they do during commercial breaks, right? And I'm saying to the audience and that the host and the guests never talk really. They just sit there next to each other.
不会吧。当我在——当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我去现场看了一场杰·雷诺的录制，我当时惊呆了，我很纳闷他们在广告期间都在干什么，对吧？我对观众说，主持人跟嘉宾其实从来都不怎么聊天。他们就并排坐在那儿。
You would just come from a taping of Price is Right, right? Cause you would have like every show. You were like, I would just watch Rod Reidy. He's had so much fun with everybody. Come on down. So then I go to Leno and I go, God, Shawn. Here's what I like about Octavia. Here's what I love about Octavia.
你当时肯定刚看完《价格猜猜猜》的录目录制吧，对吧？因为你每场秀都看。你会说：我一直在看罗德·赖迪。他跟每个人都玩得好开心。快下来吧。然后我去了雷诺的节目，我就想，天哪，肖恩。我喜欢奥克塔维亚这一点。这就是我爱奥克塔维亚的地方。
She seems like an actor's actor, right? So from the outside, I always think like certain actors or actresses, they just like become famous. And I don't know, I don't understand like where they came from, but Octavia really worked her ass off to become who she is. And we all kind of have the same circle of friends and it's like, oh, she just seems like very of actors.
她看起来就像个“演员中的演员”，对吧？所以从外行来看，我总觉得某些男演员或女演员，他们就是莫名其妙火了。我不懂，我不明白他们是从哪儿冒出来的，但奥克塔维亚真的是拼尽全力才有了今天的成就。我们其实都有差不多的朋友圈子，感觉就是，哦，她真的非常具有演员的特质。
I agree. Yeah. And there's also, you can tell that she's exactly who she is today, who she was back in the day, as opposed to some people get famous and they go, oh, I'm famous now. I can unzip this suit and zip on this one. And now I'm this guy and everybody better fucking stand back. And we've talked about it.
我同意。对。而且还有一点，你能看出来她现在的为人跟过去完全一模一样，不像有些人一旦成名了就会想：哦，我现在出名了。我可以把这身衣服脱了，换上另一身。现在我是这种大人物了，最好都特么离我远点。而且我们聊过这个。
The three of us have. We know people who fame has changed them and not necessarily for the better. Looking at two of them. Like that fucking Ryan Reynolds and Will Ferrell. I mean, Jesus Christ. Those two failing upwards. God damn it.
我们三个聊过。我们认识一些人，名气改变了他们，而且不一定是往好的方向变。看看他们俩中的某人。就像那个特么的瑞安·雷诺兹和威尔·法瑞尔。我是说，天呐。这两个家伙一路高升。真他妈的。
Obviously Ryan and Will. They slipped right through. You know what? I'm glad they're in a movie together now because maybe they'll cancel each other out. You know what I mean? Boy from your lips. I know.
显然是指瑞安和威尔。他们就这么混得风生水起。你知道吗？我很高兴他们现在一起拍了一部电影，因为这样他们或许会互相抵消对方的影响。你知道我的意思吗？借你吉言。我知道。
But you're right. You're right. Octavia does seem to have, and maybe it's also a product of the fact that she did work for so long in casting and it was a reader. So she knows what it's like and having that sort of sense of,
但你说得对。你说得对。奥克塔维亚似乎确实拥有——也许这也是她曾在选角部门工作了很长时间、当过试戏搭词员的成果。所以她知道那是什么体验，并且拥有那种心态——
I mean, the three of us know what it's like. Jason, you grew up doing this, but still, you know what it's like when things aren't going great. I was struggling. I was struggling. I got a couple of real heartbreaking callbacks for a golden ram spot that I really, really wanted.
我是说，我们三个都知道那是什么体验。杰森，你是从小干这个长大的，但即便如此，你也知道事情不顺利时的感受。我当时很挣扎。我当时很挣扎。我有几次令人心碎的复试经历，是为一个金山广告的角色，我真的、真的特别想要。
Is that true? No, no, I actually booked that one. No, but you did. You had some lean years though in all of the movie, true? Oh yeah, plenty of them, plenty of them. And Sean, you know what? That's like, it gives you perspective. Yeah, absolutely.
真的假的？不，不，其实我拿下了那个角色。不，不过你是真的有。不过你在所有那些电影里确实也经历过清苦的几年，对吧？哦对，很多次，经历过很多次。肖恩，你知道吗？那感觉就像是，这会赋予你人生视角。对，绝对的。
You know, as soon as I, I would get so nervous in casting though, like going for auditions. As soon as I, you know, got in there, I'd say hello and I would wanna, buy, tail it out of there, buy, tail it out of there, buy. No, you're on your own, you're on an island. That's not the end of the show.
你知道的，一到——我在选角时会变得超级紧张，比如去试镜。一旦我，你知道的，走进去了，我打个招呼，就恨不得赶紧逃离那个地方，夹着尾巴逃离那个地方，走。不，你得自谋生路，你就像在一个孤岛上。这还没到节目结尾呢。
You're off the fucking, that was so embarrassing. Burn your mic and shut your laptop. Jason, I mean, this is both a compliment. Here it comes now, here comes Will's, Will's gonna take a shot at it right here. Initially it's a compliment, but it's safe to say that these for you are not the lean years.
你特么离线了，刚才那一幕太尴尬了。烧了你的麦克风，关掉你的笔记本电脑吧。杰森，我是说，这既是一个恭维。现在来了，威尔的——威尔要在这儿发起一轮攻击了。起初这算是个恭维，但可以肯定地说，对你来说现在可不是什么清苦的年头。
You know, what are they? Both professionally and the way. Instead they are. These are not your lean years. Cause you're doing so well is what I mean. Because you're doing so well. And you know what I mean? It's like I, is there not a buy going in?
你知道的，那是什么？无论是从职业上还是从其他方面。相反，它们是。现在可不是你过苦日子的年头。我的意思是，因为你现在发展得太好了。因为你现在发展得太好了。你知道我的意思吗？就像我——难道没有一个“拜”字作为结尾吗？
I know, just waiting for the, I thought you were teeing yourself up, no? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I mean, basically, well, I'm taking a big buy out of the, buy. No, no, no, no, no, no, we don't have it yet. We don't have it yet. We didn't earn it.
我知道，我只是在等那个——我还以为你在给自己抛梗呢，没有吗？不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。我的意思是，基本上，好吧，我从这个“拜”字里狠狠咬了一大口。不，不，不，不，不，不，我们还没到那一步呢。我们还没到那一步。我们还没赚到这个。
We didn't earn it. We didn't have it. Thought mine was good. Yeah, no, no, yours was terrible. That was one of the worst and we're keeping that in. That was one of the worst ones. That was one of the worst. And we're keeping it in.
我们还没赚到。我们还没准备好。我觉得我那个挺好的。对，不，不，你那个太糟糕了。那是史上最差的收尾之一，而且我们要把它保留在正片里。那是史上最差之一。那是史上最差之一。而我们要把它保留下来。
We should cut that one. Nope. No, we're not going to cut it. Are you out of your fucking mind? No, no, we're keeping it. Thank you, we're keeping it. We're going to sit here and we're going to keep talking until somebody comes up with an idea
我们应该把那个剪掉。不。不，我们不会剪掉的。你特么疯了吗？不，不，我们要保留它。谢谢，我们要保留它。我们要坐在这儿，继续聊下去，直到有人想出一个点子，
and tries to gently braid it into the conversation. So again, so Octavia, fantastic, fantastic, incredible. She's there in Boston. I'm throwing out options for you guys. Sean, stop writing ideas down. Yeah, stop writing ideas. You can't try to come up and say that rhymes with high. Okay.
然后试着把它巧妙地编织进对话里。所以再次回到正题，奥克塔维亚，太棒了，太棒了，难以置信。她现在在波士顿。我在给你们出主意呢，伙计们。肖恩，别再写点子了。对，别再写点子了。你不能试图想出一个和“高”（high）押韵的词来。好吧。
Oh my God. Does it need help? No, we don't need help. We don't need any fucking help. God, would just let us sink. So I imagine what she's doing today. She's up there, she's enjoying her life. She's making a musical.
哦天哪。这需要救场吗？不，我们不需要救场。我们不需要任何他妈的救场。天呐，就让我们沉下去吧。所以我可以想象她今天在干什么。她在那儿，正享受着她的生活。她在制作一部音乐剧。
She's up there in Boston. It's a nice sunny day. And she might just get along the Charles River and just go on one of those beautiful bike trails. We've used that one before. Did we? Bye. Bye.
她现在在波士顿。那是个阳光明媚的好日子。她可能正沿着查尔斯河散步，然后去骑那些美丽的自行车道。我们之前用过这个梗了。用过吗？拜拜。再见。
Bye. Sean, you just went, bye. Like. That was terrible. Okay, you know what? Here's this. I'll tell you what. This has been the worst attempt at the end of the show.
再见。肖恩，你刚才说“拜拜”的方式。就像。那太糟糕了。好吧，你知道吗？这就是现状。我告诉你吧。这绝对是本节目史上最烂的一次结尾。
Real sloppy ending. Really sloppy. And you know what? It's left me with a taste in my mouth. My mouth is full of bile. Acceptable. Definitely acceptable. Bile.
非常潦草的结尾。真的非常潦草。而且你知道吗？这让我嘴里留下了余味。我的嘴里充满了苦胆汁。可以接受。绝对可以接受。胆汁。
Bile, you guys. Bile. Bile. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted
胆汁，伙计们。胆汁。太聪明了。没错。太聪明了。没错。SmartLess（聪明不绝）是由
by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grant Terry. The next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry app. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Rob Armjolf、Bennett Barbaco 和 Michael Grant Terry 100% 有机手工打造的。下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，或者通过 Wondry App 订阅 Wondry Plus。SmartLess（聪明不绝）。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。